hi everyone I am M and welcome to this
fantastic video on AWS Services by
simply learn but before we begin if you
enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting subscribe to our
Channel as we bring out the best videos
daily also hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn and
just a quick info for you if you want to
upscale yourself master cloud computing
skills and learn your dream job or grow
in your career then you must explore
simply learns cohort of various cloud
computing programs simply learn offers
various certifications and post-graduate
programs in collaboration with some of
the world's leading universities like
celtech I guati AWS and many more
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready expertise in
skills like serverless Computing
containerization and orchestration VPC
design and implementation and over a
dozen others and that's not all you also
get the opportunity to work on multiple
projects and learn from industry experts
working in Top Tire product companies
and academicians from top universities
after completing these courses thousands
of Learners have transitioned into a
cloud computing role as a fresher or
moved on a higher paying job and profile
if you are passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pin comment
and description box to find a cloud
computing program that fits your
experience and areas of interest and now
I think it would be a good time to talk
about what ec2 is AWS offers plenty of
services offered under different domains
like you know compute storage database
migration Network management tools Media
Services security business productivity
application integration machine learning
game development and lot more coming up
out of which ec2 falls under the compute
capacity so what is ec2 ec2 is a web
service which aims to make life life
easier for Developers for providing
secure and resizable compute capacity in
the cloud with ec2 it is very easy to
scale up or scale down our
infrastructure based on the demand and
not only that this ec2 service can be
integrated well with almost all the
services in Amazon and out of all this
the best part could be we only pay for
what we use all right let's talk about
this use case a use case here is that a
successful business owner has a bunch of
users and a successful product that's
running and now he has developed few
more products that he thinks will be
very successful that he thinks his
customers are going to like now how can
he advertise his product to his new and
prospective customers or the solution
for this question can be addressed by
AWS in AWS we can use services like
simple notification service SNS and ec2
for compute and S3 for storage we can in
a way integrate them all and achieve
this business use case and that sort of
got this business owner very cheered up
and now he wants to use the service and
he wants to get benefited from the
service he wants to advertise or he
wants to notify his users every time the
company creates a newsletter all right
so let's talk about what it would take
uh to get this environment up and
running or what it would take to connect
the environment and put the applications
on top of it firstly we would require an
AWS account and then for compute
capacity we would require an ec2
instance and here's how we go about
doing it the first thing is to create an
Ami which is Amazon Mission image that's
really the softwares and the application
packages we would need to run our
application and the second is to choose
the hardware in here it's the instance
type depending on the workload we would
be choosing the hardware and depending
on the intense of the workload we will
be choosing the size of the hardware and
finally we would uh configure the
instances and how many instance do I
want you know which subnet do I want
them in and what's going to be the you
know stop or terminate behavior of the
instance and do I want to update any
patches when the instance starts running
all those pie of information go in here
when we configure the instance and then
the first three steps is really about
the OS volume and the Basic Hardware now
it's time to add additional storage to
the ec2 instance that would be step four
here we add additional storage to the E2
instance and then tags we use tags or we
would configure tags to easily identify
an ec2 instance at a later point you
know we give it some meaningful names so
we can identify like you know which team
it belongs to which billing department
it belongs to what's the purpose behind
launching this instance stuff like that
in an environment where we run 700 to
800 are even more instances identifying
an instance and trying to understand you
know who owns the resource for what
purpose we created it could be an
full-time work so tagging comes to a
rescue at that time after tagging as
step six we would configure the fire
wall which is also called Security Group
for the ec2 instance and this is where
we would allow or deny connection from
external world to this particular ec2
instance well it works both ways from
outside and from inside out this
firewall blocks the connection based on
port number and IP address and finally
at step seven we review all the
configurations that you have done and we
make sure that the configurations is
what we wanted and finally click on
Summit that's going to launch an ec2
instance all right this was just an
overview of how to create an ec2
instance now let's talk about each and
every step in detail so to begin with
let's talk about how to create an Ami
well the Ami is just a template a
template that's used to create a new
instance or an new computer or a new VM
or a new machine based on the user
requirement the things that go into an
Ami are the software the operating
system the additional applications that
get installed in it stuff like that the
Ami will also contain software
information you know information about
uh operating system information about
access permission information about uh
volumes they all compact in the Ami
again the Ami is of two types one is
predefined Amis are called Amazon
provided Amis the other one would be
custom Amis the Amis that we create and
if you're looking at a particular Ami
that you don't want to create but still
uh want to get it from Amazon there is a
place or a portal called Ami Marketplace
there we get like thousands of Amis in
there available for us to shop and use
them on a pay as you go business model
and use them as pay as you go billing so
there you can search Ami that you're
looking for most probably you'll be able
to get it there now let's talk about
choosing the instance type the instance
type is basically the hardware
specification that's required for a
machine that we're trying to build and
the instant types is categorized into
five main families they are to begin
with it's computer optimized now
computer optimized gives us lots of
compute power or lots of processing
power so if my application is going to
require a lot of processing power I
should be picking computer optimized
instance and the second one is memory
optimized now this is very good for
application that require inmemory
caching you know there are some
application that performs well with
cache or through cache or the
application would create a lot of data
that it wants to keep in Cache for
rereading or for processing you know for
lengthy processing stuff like that for
those type of application this memory
optimized instance that comes within
memory cache is a very good use case and
the third one is the instant that comes
with the GPU otherwise called GPU
optimized GPU stands for graphical
process unit and this is very good for
application that deals with gaming this
is very good for application that's
going to require large graphical
requirements and storage optimized is
the fourth option just like the name
says this is very good use case for
storage servers and the fifth family
type is general purpose just like the
name says it's for general purpose if
you're not particular about the family
then you generally would end up picking
the general purpose because here the
services are sort of equally balanced
you know you'll find a balance between
the virtual CPU and the memory and the
storage and the network performance it's
sort of balanced all the components all
the features that needs to go in a
computer are sort of balanced balanced
in general purpose now these instant
types are fixed and they cannot be
altered because it's Hardware based we
buy Hardware we do not have much control
on the hardware that's being used well
we have options but we do not have
control on the hardware and these
instant types are divided into five main
families they are computer optimized
memory optimized GPU enabled storage
optimized and general purpose then as
third thing we have to configure the in
instance now here is where I have lot of
options about uh purchasing you know
what type of purchasing do I want to do
do I want to go for a spot instance do I
want to go for a reserved instance do I
want to go for an ond demand instance
these are different billing options
available and that's available under
configure instance not only that here is
where I'm going to put the ec2 instance
do I want an public IP adders assigned
to it do I want an IM am Ro attached to
it IM am Ro is authentication what kind
of authentication am I going to provide
and uh the shut on Behavior the shut on
behaviors include do I want to stop the
instance when the user shuts down the
machine from the desktop or do I want to
Simply terminate the in instance when
the user shuts down the instance from
the desktop so those things go in here
just like the name says configure
instance lot of instance configuration
options comes in here that's the third
step and not only that under the
advanced details or Advanced tab under
configure instance I can bootstrap the
instance with some scripts now bootstrap
is nothing but the scripts that you want
to be run in the instance before it
actually comes online let's say you're
provisioning the instance for somebody
else you know instead of you launching
the instance and then logging in and
running some commands and then handing
it over to the other person you can
create bootstrap shell scripts and uh
you know paste it in a console option
available under configuration instance
and Amazon is going to take those
commands run it on the instance before
it hands over to the user that initially
requested for that instance now it could
be a different user or just you it sort
of automates you know software
installation procedures in the instance
that we will be launching and not only
that there are multiple payment options
available under configure instance the
user can pick an instance under normal
price and that instance would apply
normal rates applied to it and there are
also options like reserved instance
where the user can pay for an instance
upfront before a year or before months
you know for a span of year or a span of
months and that way they can pay less
per hour for using that instance not
only that you can also go for spot
instance like bidding for those
instances whoever bids more they get the
instance for that particular time well
these instances are a lot cheaper than
than OnDemand instances and through
bidding and buying you can keep the
instance as long as your bid price
doesn't exceed the price that Amazon is
proposing and as the fourth step we will
have to add storage to the instance that
we are about to launch and here we have
bunch of storage options I can go for a
peral storage which is free or I can go
for an external elastic block storage
also called EBS which is paid and it's a
permanent storage or else I can
integrate my ec2 instance with S3 for
its storage needs and the best part
about storage is a free subscription
users they get to use 30 GB of SSD
storage or magnetic storage for the
whole year in this page where we are
ready to add storage we will have to
mention or provide the size in gigabit
and the volume type is it going to be an
a provisioned volume is it going to be
an general purpose volume is it it going
to be a magnetic volume stuff like that
they are volume types and we also need
to give inputs about where the dis will
be mounted and whether this volume needs
to be encrypted or not so all these
options or all these inputs are received
from us under the adding storage section
and then the fifth option would be
adding tags like we discussed some time
back tags are very helpful to identify a
machine in an environment where we have
700 or th000 VMS running and Security
Group are the actual firewall that sits
in front of ec2 instance and it protects
that ec2 instance from unintended
inbound and outbound traffic now here is
where I can fine-tune the access to my
ec2 instance based on port numbers and
based on IP address from which it can be
accessed and finally we get to review
the whole changes or the whole
configurations that we have made to find
out whether they are intact with the
requirement and then click on submit
that's going to launch launch an ec2
instance but hold on we're not done yet
when we're about to launch or before the
Amazon console actually launches the ec2
instance it's going to give us an option
to create a keypad remember I said it's
key pair you know key pair is two things
one is public and private the private
key is downloaded by the user and is
kept with the user and the public key is
used by Amazon to confirm the identity
of the user so just go ahead and
download the the private key and keep it
for yourself and this private key gets
downloaded as a pem file it's a format
of the file and it gets downloaded as PM
file and our next step is to access the
ec2 instance and because the instance
that we have launched in this example
let's assume it's Linux instance and
that's going to require a tool called
puty to be able to access it and this
puty tool is really needed when we
trying to access an Linux instance from
Windows instance most of the time
Windows instance will have puty
installed in them but in some rare cases
they do not come with puty in those
cases we can go ahead and download puty
and puty Generator and we can start
using it to access the Linux instance
now you might ask well I understand puty
what's puty generator now the file that
we have downloaded is in PM format but
unfortunately puty does not accept PM
format as input you know it has to be
converted into a different format called
PPK and puty gen is a tool that helps us
to convert the PM file into PPK file so
the quick way to do it is download
generator open it up click on conversion
and insert the pem key that we have
downloaded and save the private key and
this when we save the private key it
gets saved as a PPK type private key and
when that's done the next very step is
to open puty and try to log in and the
way to log in is to open puty put that
IP address here and then click on Au you
know this is where we would input the
file that we have created so click on op
and then click on browse and find the
PPK file that we have converted and
stored browse it and upload it and then
click on open now that's going to open
up a login screen for us and the Amis
comes with a default username depending
on the Ami that we have picked the
username might differ in our case we
have picked an Ami for which the
username is E2 hyphen user and this is
the default by the way let's put the
username E2 hyphen user and hit enter
and that's going to open up the Linux
instance using CLI there are a few other
things that we can do with the terminal
that we'll explain it a little later all
right so we have successfully launched
an ec2 instance and um yeah give
yourself a pat on your back launching an
instance was just one part of the
solution so let's actually talk about
how we can notify our customers SNS or
simple notification service is a service
or a product in Amazon that helps us to
notify customers through email so uh
navigate to SNS in your account and
create a topic and we're going to use
this topic for public notification so
let's make it public and then add
subscribers to it now these subscri
subcribers these subscribers are the
people who you want to be notified about
the newsletter so we already have the
email database in there add them to the
subscribers list and then they will
start getting new newsletters as in when
we post them to the topic and as Next
Step create a bucket in S3 where you can
store content and in that bucket create
an event that triggers a notification to
simple notification service so this is
how it will be set up and notification
will be sent to our subscribers anytime
we put something in our S3 bucket so S3
bucket is going to create an event for
the notification and the notification is
going to make sure that it's delivered
to your end Customer because they're
already subscribed to the topic as
subscribers and finally let's connect
the S3 with ec2 so the bucket and the
AWS instance are in sync so we put some
content in the S3 bucket our email
system notifies our customers and the
customers can go online to a website
that's hosted in ec2 and because S3 and
ec2 are in sync the items that we put in
S3 will also show up in ec2 see how this
is all connected and it's working
together and once this is all connected
our subscribers will regularly be
informed anytime we put new content in
the S3 bucket and the same content will
be made available in ec2 instance
through the website it so what is S3 S3
stands for simple storage service and it
is an object storage service in Amazon
what this means is that it doesn't
matter what kind of file you upload to
S3 it will be treated as an abstraction
meaning an object so you can upload a
PDF file you can upload a JPEG file you
can upload a database backup it doesn't
really matter all that is abstracted
Away by the use of storing it within an
object we're going to talk more about
what composes an object but by doing so
what happens is is S3 allows us to have
industry uh leading scalability so it
doesn't matter if you're going to make a
request for that database backup let's
say that object um five times or 10,000
times that requests that demand will
scale the underlying infrastructure that
is implemented behind the scen
is handled for you so in a sense it's
kind of like a
serverless service a storage service
where you're not implicated in handling
anything underneath the covers you're
just uploading your objects and
accessing them later on in terms of data
availability very powerful as well
because it takes those objects and will
replicate them across at least three
availability zones of course these
availability zones have one or more data
centers attached to them so you have
lots and lots of copies of your objects
distributed globally or at least at a
regional uh in a regional area uh you
can do this as well globally if you
enable global
replication um and you will see that
your level of dur availability will
Skyrocket and you're just not going to
worry about losing an S3
object data security well we can encrypt
our data at rest our objects at rest we
can encrypt it in transit we can also
come up with security policies at uh the
Bucket Level which we're going to talk
about what a bucket is very very very
soon um these are going to be
implemented through what's called I am
policies and you're going to be able to
control who or what has access to your
objects and of course because everything
is handled underneath the covers all the
servers all the storage nodes are Cloud
optimized for the best
possible
performance so let's continue on our
journey on what is S3 we're going to
take a look at what is a bucket and what
is an object as you can see here you
have inside this bucket which is a
logical container for an unlimited
amount of objects you could have objects
of different shapes and sizes like I
said you could have pictures database
backups Etc so this is what's being
represented here by different shapes and
and you can think of a bucket really as
almost like a folder where objects or
files are placed within them so there
are many ways for us to place objects
within a bucket we can do this through
the AWS console which I'll be showing
you very shortly we can do this via the
command line interface or we can do this
through a software development kit at
the end of the day all those three
options go through an API right so it's
all about picking the right method that
is best suited for whatever kind of end
user or application that needs access to
these buckets and to these objects now
once you've got the data or objects
within this bucket you can control
pretty much how the data is accessed how
it's stored whether you want it to be
encrypted and how it's even managed so
you can have organizations that have
specific compliance needs for example
any objects uh that are placed in there
perhaps some PDFs are not to be modified
or not to be touched for 90 days let's
say we can imply um object locks if we
want to we can imply security guards we
can also for example uh record all API
actions that try to access to list to
delete any kind of API operations on
those objects at the Bucket Level or on
the object level we can record if that
is some sort of organizational
compliance need for auditing or for
whatever internal um auditing reason
that you may
have so continuing on here you can see
that there are many organizations that
use S3 one in point is Amazon itself S3
is so popular and so durable that Amazon
internally uses it to store its own data
you're guaranteed you know almost that
you're not going to lose any object in
there because it has what we call
119 durability now 119 durability is
really an extreme amount of durability
where it's
mathematically almost impossible for you
to lose an object once you placed it in
S3 you're in fact more uh liable to get
hit by meteorite then you are to lose an
object in S3 statistically speaking
which is a pretty incredible statistic
but it's but it's
true so if we continue here with the
benefits of S3 some of these I've
already uh described but let's talk
about the full um picture here we see
the performance scalability availability
and
durability um of S3 are really uh you
know first class in the industry again
durability we were talking about that
119 so what that really means is 9
99.9999 in total if you count all the
nines that's 11 of those nines so um ex
most durable in the industry by far and
again because everything is handled
underneath the covers it's a
serverless service uh they ensure the
scalability and availability and the
performance of um the inner workings of
that object level storage now cost is of
course always important and S3 really
shows up here with first class support
again for cost it's got very very low
cost we can have object level storage
for um let's say a terabyte of object
level storage for as little as a dollar
a month so again it will depend on the
kind of storage class we're going to
have a discussion on different types of
storage classes that we might want to
transition or move over our objects from
one storage class to the the next
depending on how frequently accessed
that data is as you know data over time
seems to get less and less accessed as
you know your needs shift from one place
to another we're going to talk about
that coming up very soon so we're going
to want to really focus on that to
reduce our end of the month costs for
storage with S3 of course security is
always at the Forefront and we want to
make sure that we either
simply secure by encrypting everything
right off the bat either at rest in
transit or we want to put an object lock
or just maintain security at the Bucket
Level maintaining let's say who or what
has access to that data because by
default no one has access to the data
unless we open up the door and also we
want to make sure that we don't give
public access to our bucket for obvious
reasons of of uh giving away important
information by mistake so AWS makes it
extremely difficult for you to
accidentally do this and I'm going to
show this in a demonstration lab uh
coming up very
soon and we can also query in place
which is very interesting so you can
imagine you putting let's say um a file
that's in CSV format or Json format or
parket format some sort of structured
format or semi-structured format in S3
and you could actually use SQL queries
on the spot to filter that data in place
at the Bucket Level you can also have
other services that may want to extract
some business intelligence uh from that
data in your S3 bucket directly as well
so some other more advanced quering
operations can take place at the S3
level so this you will learn during your
journey with simply learn as you're
covering all the AWS technology stacks
and here the most widely used storage
cloud service in the industry uh because
of all the points that we just covered
it really is the number one storage or
object level storage solution in the
industry let's now take a look at
objects and buckets and S3 so the
objects are really the fundamental
entities that are stored in S3 or the
lowest common denominator which means
that we're not really interested in what
kind of data is within the object at at
the layer of S3 because S3 doesn't have
direct access to the data within an
object like I said before it's an
abstraction of the data so we don't know
if it's a cat picture if it's a backup
of your database it's just treated as a
fundamental entity aka the object now
every object is associated with metadata
so data about itself things like what's
the name of the object what's the size
the time and date that the object was
uploaded things of that nature are
categorized as metadata so S3 does have
direct access to that now the data
within that object of course is
accessible by other services so it's not
that once you've uploaded it you've
totally lost the data and it's only can
be treated as an object it's just that
at this
layer it's simply just assign metadata
and a version ID a unique version ID and
if you re-upload the exact same object a
second or third time to S3 it will have
its own version ID number so a new
unique version ID number will be
generated so really what buckets are are
there logical containers to store those
objects so of course at an extremely
high level a bucket would be like your
root file system if you want to think
about it like that but that doesn't mean
you can't go into this bucket and create
separate folders now when you create
separate folders in a bucket because you
might want to logically organize all
your
objects you might be fooled by the fact
that you think this is a hierarchal
storage system when in fact it is not
and I'll talk about that in a second so
you cannot store an object without first
storing it into a bucket so of course
the first step would be for us to create
a bucket and then upload objects within
that bucket so an object cannot can
cannot exist without its container or
its
bucket so there's no windows explor view
like we're used to in an operating
system because this is not a hierarchal
view no matter if you create folder
within folders within folders in fact
S3's internal architecture is a flat
hierarchy what we do instead is we
assign prefixes which are treated as
folders in order to logically organize
our objects within our buckets and I'm
going to Showcase a prefix in one of the
demonstrations coming up very
soon so when you create or when you're
working with S3 first of all you're work
looking at a regional level you're going
to have to pick a region for example you
might pick us East one region or Us East
2 region and the bucket that you're
going to be creating will be replicated
across several availability zones but
within that region also that data those
objects can be accessed globally because
S3 uses the HTTP protocol HTTP protocol
is very permissive everybody knows how
to ad administrate it and work with it
so we just need to give access to that
object in terms of a permission policy
and give it the
proper uh URL or give whoever needs
access to it the proper URL and they can
access that VI HTTP globally so first
when you're creating a bucket you have
to select the region and the object will
live within that region but that doesn't
mean that it still can't be accessed
globally so let's now take a minute go
over to the AWS console and actually let
me showcase how to create uh objects and
buckets so for our first lab we're going
to be going and creating an S3 bucket
and uploading an object to it so we
first have to log into the AWS console
which we have up here in the address bar
let's click on either create free
account if it's your very first time or
as an is in my case uh already have an
account and we're going to sign in
here you're going to have to pass in
your um IM username password and your um
account ID of
course once you've logged in you can
search for the simple uh storage service
S3 either uh by coming up here in the
search box and typing S3 and you'll find
it there that's probably the easiest way
or if you want you can take a look at
all the services and it'll be under
storage over here the first one okay so
pick whichever method you see best for
yourself once we're here we want to
create our first bucket now I've already
have a couple of buckets here so we're
going to go on and create a new bucket
the very first thing is you have to
specify a bucket name now this bucket
name has to be globally unique if you
take a look here at the region that
we're in it doesn't actually select a re
specific region it selects the global
option which means that this bucket will
become globally accessible so that is
why it needs to have a unique name much
like a DNS name has to be unique for
your website right so I'm going to come
up
here and pick a name that I think is
going to be unique so I'm going to say
simply
learn S3
demo all right let's take a look at if
that's going to work out of course we
have to pick pick a region but it is
globally accessible so you either pick a
region that's closest to your end users
or in our case since we're just doing a
demonstration we can do whichever is
closer to us right now okay and we're
going to skip these options for now
we're going to come back to them later
on we're just going to create the
bucket now hopefully that was a unique
name and allowed me to create that and
it looks like it did so if I scroll down
you can see that uh it clearly got
created over over here now we're going
to click on that and we are going to
start uploading objects to this bucket
so let me click on the upload button and
you can either select one or more files
or you can select an entire folder so
I'm going to just go and select a
specific cat picture that I have
here okay and again we'll go through
some of those other options later on and
we'll just click
upload now this should take no time at
all because of the fact that's a very
small object or file that's being
uploaded so it is has succeeded we can
close this up and we see now clearly
that the object is in our bucket if we
go to properties we can see the metadata
associated with this bucket we can see
the region that it's in we can see the
Arn which is the Amazon resource name
which uniquely identifies this resource
this bucket
um across the globe so if ever you
needed to reference this let's say uh in
an I am policy or whatever other service
needed to communicate with S3 you would
need this Arn it's a very important
piece of information and of course we
have their creation date so some high
level metadata so objects as we have
covered already consist of not only the
data itself but the metadata so there's
lots of metadata and there's a lot of
other features that we can go here and
enable very easily and this will be the
basis of the future uh demonstrations
that I'm going to do all right so just
to recap what we just did we created a
unique bucket give it a name of Simply
learn S3 demo and uploaded our first
object to
it so let's now take a look at the inner
workings of the Amazon S3
when we upload an object into a bucket
we have to select which one of these
storage classes the object will reside
in so you see have six storage classes
here at the bottom and each have their
own characteristics that we're going to
get into by default if you don't specify
anything it'll get placed in What's
called the S3 standard storage class
which is the most expensive out of all
these storage
classes once your object gets colder and
what I mean by colder is your access
patterns diminish meaning that you're
accessing that file less and less over
the course of time so it gets colder you
will transition that object from one
tier to the next all the way to for
example S3 deep archive so again deep
archive signifies extremely cold so
maybe you're only referencing this data
once a year once every couple of years
and so you want to have the cheapest
possible storage available so right now
you can get about one terabyte of
storage per month for about a dollar a
month with S3 uh glacer deep archive so
you are going to be very interested in
knowing how to transition from one or
more of these storage classes over time
in order to save on your storage costs
that's really why we're doing this so
let's go through some of the storage
classes by default like I said
whenever you upload an object you
automatically get placed into the
standard storage class so any files that
you're working on frequently daily this
is the best fit for it you've got the
highest level of accessibility and um
durability as well not that the others
don't have the same level of durability
however we'll see how when you
transition from one storage tier to the
next some characteristics do change in
in order for you to save on some costs
we're going to go through some of those
now this would be considered hot data
right data that's used all the time
maybe just by you maybe by everybody
right so that's the perfect place to
place it in the standard storage class
now over time like I said you may find
yourself working less and less perhaps
on a document that was due by the end of
the month that document was submitted
and then afterwards you don't work on
that document anymore perhaps you're
only working on revisions based on
feedback from your colleagues that are
asking you to make some corrections or
some amendments and so only those uh
Corrections or amendments come in
perhaps once a month and so in that case
you might find yourself um finding a
justification for moving that document
from the standard tier to the standard i
a or in frequently accessed here maybe
any objects U not modified for more than
30 days are a good fit for that and
that's really the criteria for IIA
inactive access is that S3 or AWS itself
recommends to only put objects in there
if they haven't been as access for at
least 30 days so you get a a price
reduction a rebate for putting objects
that are not accessed frequently in here
of course if you remove objects let's
say before the
30-day uh limit then you are charged a
charge for retrieving an object that you
said was infrequently accessed but it
really was not so bear that in mind if
you're going to place objects in
infrequent access be somewhat uh
reasonably assured that you're not going
to be going there and accessing them you
can still access those files no problem
just as quickly they have the same level
of accessibility and durability however
like I said anything less than 30 days
you'll get a price in on that if you
want to have long-term storage we're
talking about Amazon Glacier so this is
more anything um over 90 days that
hasn't been modified or 180 days there's
two subcategories of Amazon Glacier that
we're going to get into and this is the
cheapest storage by far and Amazon
Glacier doesn't really operate through
the AWS console as the same as the
standard and the infrequent access you
can't really upload objects to Glacier
via the um console in the browser you
can only do so let's say through the
commandline interface or through an SDK
the only thing you can do on the web
console with Glacier is actually create
what's called a vault which is a logical
container for your archives but then
after that you have to go through the
CLI or the SDK to do the rest of the
work
there if we continue on there's some
gray areas between between uh the S3
standard in the glacier one is the one
zone in frequently accessed storage
class so if we go back to the regular uh
standard and IIA storage class all of
these objects are stored across a
minimum of three availability zones if
you want a further price reduction you
can store your objects in a one zone IIA
storage class which means that instead
of taking that object and replicating it
across three or more availability zones
it will only store it in a single
availability Zone therefore
reducing uh the level of availability
that you have to that object so in this
case here if that single availability
Zone would go down for example you would
not have access to that object once it
would come back up of course you would
the other thing is is if there was a an
immense catastrophe where the actual
availabilities Zone was destroyed well
of course then your object is also gone
so if that's something that doesn't
worry you because you have already many
copies of this object may be lying
around on premise then this is a good
option for you because it's data that
you're willing to lose or lose access to
for short periods of time if ever that
single availability Zone goes down so
it's about an extra 20% off the price
from already the normal uh IIA standard
price there is another one called the
standard reduced redundancy
storage this one is kind of getting
phased out as we speak because the same
price for this storage class is about
the same amount you're going to pay for
the normal IIA standard class what this
does is again is a good fit for um your
object that you're not really worried
about losing if there is some sort of
catastrophe that happens in an
availability Zone there's less copies of
it that are stored and so if that data
center and that availability Zone goes
down then you lose your object so of
course it offered at the time the
highest price reduction uh possible but
now the difference between this one and
the normal IIA standard storage class is
so small in terms of price that you're
probably not going to uh migrate to um
or navigate to this storage class but it
is still there in the documentation and
it may very well come up still in the um
certification exam so at least be aware
of
that let's now take a look at some
individual features of S3 starting off
with life cycle management so life cycle
management is very interesting because
it allows us to come up with a
predefined rule that will help us
automate the transitioning of objects
from one storage class to another
without us having to manually copy
things over of course you could imagine
how time consuming that would be if we
had to do this
manually so we're going to see this very
soon in a lab however let me discuss how
uh how this works so once we uh it's
basically a graphical user interface
it's very very simple to use once you
come up with these uh life cycle
management rules but you're going to
Define two things you're going to define
the transition action and the expiration
action so the transition action is going
to be something like well I want to
transition an object from maybe it's all
objects or maybe it's just a specific
type of object in a folder example that
has a specific prefix from one storage
class let's say standard to standard
inactive or infrequent access maybe only
after 45 days after at least a minimum
of 30 days like we spoke of before and
then maybe after uh 90 days you want to
transition the objects in IIA to right
away Glacier deep archive or 180 days
you come up with whatever combination
you see fit okay it doesn't have to be
sequential from S3 to IIA to one zone
etc etc because like we discussed before
it depends what kind of objects that
you're interested in putting in one zone
objects that you don't really mind
losing if that one availability Zone
goes down so you're going to be deciding
those rules it ends up that this even is
not a simple task because you have to
monitor your usage patterns to see which
data is hot which data is cold and
what's the best kind of life cycle
management to implement to reap the
benefits of the lowest cost so you have
to put somebody on this job and and make
the best informed uh decisions based on
your axis patterns and that is something
that you need to consistently monitor so
what we can do is we can instead opt for
something called S3 intelligent
taring which basically analyzes your
workload using machine learning
algorithms and after about a good 30
days of analyzing your access patterns
will automatically be able to transition
your objects from s 3 standard to S3
standard in frequent access okay it
doesn't go past the iia1 doesn't go
after the glacier and whatnot okay so it
can then offer you um that at a reduced
um price overhead so there is a
monitoring fee that is introduced in
order to uh implement this feature it's
a very nominal very very low monitoring
fee and the nice thing is is if if ever
you take out an object out of the
infrequent axis before the 30-day limit
as we spoke of before you will not be
charged um an overhead charge because of
that why because you're using the
intelligent tearing you're already
paying an overhead for the monitoring
fee so at least in that sense the
intelligent tearing will take the object
out of IIA and put it back into the S3
standard class if you need access to it
before the 30 days and in that case you
w be charged that overhead so that is
something that is
very um that is very um good to to to do
in order not to have to put somebody on
that job so yes you're paying a little
bit of overhead for that monitoring Fe
but at the other side of the spectrum
you're not investing in somebody uh
working many hours to Monitor and put
into place a system to monitor your data
access patterns so let's take a look at
how to do this right now let's Implement
our own life cycle management
rules so let's now create a life cycle
rule inside our bucket first off we're
going to need to go to the management
Tab and the bucket that we just created
and right on the top you see right away
life cycle rule we're going to create
life cycle rule and we're going to name
it so I'm just going to say something
very uh simple like
simply learn
uh life cycle
rule and we have the option of creating
this rule for every single object in the
bucket or we can limit the scope to a
certain type of file perhaps with a
prefix like I could see one right now
something like log so anything that we
categorize as a log file will transition
from one storage tier to the next as per
our instructions we're doing this
because we really want to save on costs
right it's not so much of organizing
what's your older data versus your newer
data it's more about reducing that
storage cost as your objects get less
and less used so in this case logs are a
good fit because perhaps you're using
your logs for the first 30 days you're
sifting through them um you're trying to
get insights on them but then you kind
of move them out of the way because they
become old data and you don't need them
anymore so we're going to see how we can
uh transition them to another pricing
tier another storage tier uh we could
also do this with object tags which is a
very powerful feature and in the life
cycle rules action you have to at least
pick one of these options now since we
haven't enabled versioning yet what I'm
going to do is just select transition
the current version of the object
between these storage classes so as a
reminder of what we already covered in
the slid our storage classes are right
over here so the one that's missing is
obviously the default standard storage
class which all objects are placed in by
default so what we're going to say is
this we want our objects that are in the
default standard storage class to go to
the standard inactive access storage
class after 30 days and that'll give us
a nice discount on those objects being
stored then we want to add another
transition and let's say we want to
transition them to Glacier after 90 days
and then as a big finale we want to go
to Glacier deep archive you can see the
rest are grayed out would it make sense
to go back and maybe after 180 days we
want to go there okay now there's a
little bit of um a warning or call to
attention here they're saying if you're
going to store very small
files um into glacier not a great idea
there's an overhead in terms of metadata
that's added and also there's an
additional cost associated with storing
small files in Glacier so we're just
going to acknowledge that of course for
the demonstration that's fine in real
life you don't want to store very big
tar files or zip files that had you know
one or more lock files in there okay
that would bypass that that search
charge that you would get and over here
you have the timeline summary of
everything we selected up above so we
have here after 30 days the standard
inactive access after 90 days Glacier
and after 180 days Glacier deep archive
so let's go and create that
rule all right so we see that the rule
is already enabled and at any time you
could go back and disable this if ever
you had um a reason to do so we can
easily delete it as well or view the
details and and edited as well so if we
go back to our bucket now what I've done
is created that prefix with the slash
logs since we're not doing this from the
command line we're going to create a
logs folder over here that will fit that
prefix so create
logs create folder and now we're going
to upload our let's say Apache log files
in here so we're going to upload one
demonstration Apache log file that I've
created with just one line in there of
course just for demonstration purposes
we're going to upload
that and now we have we're just close
that and now we have our our Pache log
file in there so what's going to happen
because we have that life cycle rule in
place after 30 days anything any file
that has the logs prefix or basically is
placed inside this folder will be
transitioned as per that life cycle Ru
policy that we just created so
congratulations you just created your
first first S3 life cycle Ru
policy let's now move over to bucket
policies so bucket policies are going to
allow or deny access to not only the
bucket itself but the objects within
those buckets to either specific users
or other services that are inside the
AWS Network now these policies fall
under the category of IM am policy so IM
stands for identity and access
management and this is a whole other
topic that deals with security at large
so there are no services in AWS which
are allowed to access other services or
data for example within S3 without you
explicitly allowing it through these IM
policies so one of the ways we do that
is by attaching one of these policies
which are written in a Json format so
it's a text file that we write at the
end of the day that's the artifact and
that's a good thing because we can use
that artifact and we can configuration
control it in our source control and
version it and put it alongside our
source code so when we deploy everything
it is part of our deployment package so
in this case here we have several ways
of doing this we can use What's called
the policy generator which is a
graphical user interface that allows us
to Simply click and point and populate
certain text boxes which will then
generate that Json document that will
allow us to attach that to our S3 bucket
and that will determine like I said
which users or Services have access to
uh whatever API actions are available
for that resource so we might say we
want certain users to be able just to
list the contents of this bucket not
necessarily be able to delete or upload
new objects into that bucket so you can
get very fine grained permissions based
on the kind of actions you want to allow
on this resource so in order to really
bring this home let's go and perform our
very own lab on this
let's now see how to create an S3 bucket
policy going back to our bucket we're
now going to go into
permissions so the whole point of coming
up with a bucket policy is that we want
to control who or what the what being
other services have access to our bucket
and our objects within our bucket so
there are several ways we can go about
doing this let's edit a bucket
policy one we can go and look at a whole
bunch of preann examples which is a good
thing to do two we could actually go in
here and code the Json document
ourselves which is much more difficult
of course so what we're going to do is
we're going to look at a policy
generator which is really a form-based
graphical user interface that allows us
to generate through the answers that
we're going to give here the Json
document for us first question is we got
to select the policy type of course
we're dealing with S3 so would make
sense for us to create an S3 bucket
policy the two options available to us
are allowing or
denying access to our S3 bucket now in
this case here we could get really um
fine grain and specify certain kinds of
services or certain kinds of users but
for the demonstration we're just going
to select star which means anything or
anybody can access this S3 bucket all
right now depending on uh also the
actions that we're going to allow so in
this case here we can get very fine
grain and we have all these check boxes
that we can check off to give access to
certain kind of API action so we can say
we want to give access to you know just
deleting the bucket which obviously is
something very powerful uh but you can
get more fine grain as you can see you
have more of the Getters over here um
and you have more of the the the listing
and the putting new objects in there as
well so you can get very fine grain now
for demonstration purposes we're going
to say all action so this is a very
Broad and wide ranging permission
something that you really should think
twice about before doing we're basically
saying we want to allow everybody and
anything any service all API actions on
this S3 bucket so so that's no uh small
thing we need to specify the Amazon
resource name the Arn of that bucket
specifically so what we're going to do
is go back to our
bucket and you can see here uh the
bucket Arn okay so we're just going to
copy
this paste it in this policy generator
and just say add statement you can see
here kind of a resume of what we just
did and we're going to say generate
policy and this this is where it creates
for us and make this a little bit bigger
for us it creates that Json document so
we're going to take this we're going to
copy it and we're going to paste it
into the generator okay now of course we
could flip this and change this to a
deny right which would basically say we
don't want anybody to have access or any
thing any other service to have access
to this S3 bucket we could even say
slashstar to also encapsulate all the
objects within that bucket so if I save
this right
now you have a very
Ironclad S3 bucket policy which
basically denies all access to uh this
bucket and the objects within of course
this is on the other side of the
spectrum very very secure so we might
want to for example host a static
website through our S3 bucket so in this
case here allowing access would make
more sense right so if I save changes
you see that we get an errror here
saying that we don't have permissions to
do this and the reason for that is
because it realizes that this is
extremely permissive so in order to give
access to every single object within
this bucket as in the case that I was
stating of a static website being hosted
on your S3 bucket it would be much
better to also at first enable
that option so I'm just going to
duplicate the tab
here and once you go back to the
permissions tab one of the first things
that shows up is this block block Public
Access setting right right now it's
completely blocked and that's what's
stopping us from saving our policy we
would have to go in here unblock it and
save it right and it's also kind of like
a double clutch feature you have to
confirm that just so you don't do that
by by accident right so now what you've
effectively done is you've really opened
up the floodgates to have public access
to this bucket it's something that can't
be accidentally done it's kind of like
having to perform these two actions
before the public access can be granted
now
historically this was something that AWS
was um
was guilty of was making it too easy to
have Public Access so now we have this
double clutch now that this is enabled
or turned off we can now
save our changes here successfully and
you can see here that now it's publicly
accessible which is a big red flag that
perhaps this is not something that
you're interested in doing now if you're
hosting a public website and you want
everybody just to have read access to
every single object in your bucket yes
this is fine however please make sure
that you um pay very close attention to
this uh type of access flagged over here
on the console so congratulations you
just got introduced to your first bucket
policy a permissive one but at least now
you know how to go through that
graphical user interface through the
policy generator and create them and
paste them inside your S3 bucket policy
uh
paint
so let's continue on with data
encryption so any data that you place in
S3 bucket can be encrypted at rest very
easily using an ases 256 encryption key
so we can have server side encryption we
could have AWS handle all the encryption
for us and the decryption will also be
handled by AWS when we request our
objects later on but we could also have
have client side encryption where we the
client that are uploading the object
have to be responsible for also passing
over our own generated key that will
eventually be used by AWS to then
encrypt that object on the bucket side
of course once that happens then the key
is discarded the client key is discarded
and you have to be very mindful that
since you've decided to handle your own
own encryption client side encryption
that if ever you lose those keys well
that data is not going to be recoverable
in that bucket on the AWS Network so be
very careful on that
point we can also have a very useful
feature called versioning which will
allow you to have a history of all the
changes of an object over time so
versioning sounds exactly how it's named
and every time you make a modification
to a file and upload that new version to
S3 it will have a brand new version ID
associated with that so over time you
get a sort of stack of a history of all
the file changes over time so you can
see here at the bottom you have an ID
with all these ones and then an ID with
one
121212 So eventually if ever you wanted
to revert back to a previous version
you could do so by uh accessing one of
those previous versions of course
versioning is not an option that's
enabled by default you have to go ahead
and enable that yourself it is an
extremely simple thing to do and so
there may be a situation where you
already have objects within your buckets
and you only then enable versioning well
versioning would only apply to the new
objects that would get uploaded from the
point that you enabled versioning the
objects that were there before that
point will not get a specific version
number attached in fact they will have a
sort of null marker um version number
that will get attached to them it's only
after that you modify those objects
later on and upload a new version that
they will get their own version
numbers so right now what we're going to
be doing is a lab on actual uh
versioning so let's go ahead and do that
right
now in this lab we're going to see how
to enable versioning in our buckets
enable versioning is very easy we're
simply going to click on our bucket go
into properties and there is going to be
a bucket versioning section we going to
click on edit and enable
it once that's done any new objects that
are uploaded to that S3 bucket will now
benefit from being tracked by a version
number so if you upload objects with the
same file name after that they'll each
have a different version number so
you'll have version tracking a history
of the changes for that object let's
actually go there and upload a new
file I'll upload one called
index.html so we're going to simulate a
situation where we've decided we're
going to use an S3 bucket as the source
of our static website to deploy one and
in this index.html file if you take a
look uh right now let's take a look at
what's in there you can see that we have
welcome to my website and we're at
version two okay so if I click on this
file right
now and I go to
versions I can clearly see that there's
some version activ ity that's happening
here okay we have here um at 1456 which
is the latest one the latest one is on
the top the current version we have a
specific version ID and then we have a
sort of history of what's going on here
now I purposely enabled versioning
before and then try
to delete versioning or disable
versioning but here's the thing with
versioning you cannot disable it fully
once it's enabled you can only suspend
it right now suspending means that
whatever version numbers those objects
had before you decided to suspend it
will remain so you can see I have an
older version here that has an older
version number and at this point here I
decided to suspend versioning and so
what it does instead of disabling the
entire history it puts what's called a
delete marker okay you could always roll
back to that version if you want now in
the demonstration when we started it
together I enabled it again so you can
see this is actually the brand new
version number as we did it together but
you don't lose the history of previous
versioning if ever you had suspended it
before so that's something to keep in
mind right and it'll come up in the exam
where they'll ask you can you actually
disable versioning once it's enabled and
the answer is no you could only suspend
it and your history is still maintained
now we have that version there and let's
say I come to this file and I want to
upgrade this I don't know I say version
three right and now what's going to
happen is if I click on this version
this is the current one with version two
and I open this we should see version
two which is fine that's that's that's
expected if we go back to our bucket and
up upload that new version file that has
version three in there want I just
modify
it we should now see in that index.html
file a brand new version that was
created under the versions Tab and there
you go 1458 just 2 minutes after you
could see here we have a brand new
version ID right and if I open this
one you can see version three so now you
have a way
to enable versioning very easily in your
buckets and you also have seen what
happens when you want to suspend
versioning what happens to the history
of those versions files before just to
actually go back here to the
properties uh where we enabled
versioning in the first place if I want
to go back in here and disable it like I
said you can't disable you can only
suspend and that's where that delete
marker gets placed but all your previous
version
retain their version ID so don't forget
that because that will definitely be a
question on your exam if you're
interested in taking the certification
exam so congratulations you just learned
how to enable
versioning let's move on to cross region
replication or crr as it is known there
will be many times when you find
yourself with objects in a bucket and
you want to share those objects with
another bucket now that other bucket
could be within the same account could
be within another account within the
same region or could be within a
separate account in a different region
so there's varying levels of degree
there the good thing is is all of
those um combinations are available so
crr if we're talking about cross region
replication is really about replicating
objects across regions something that is
not enabled by default because that will
incur a replication charge because it's
sinking objects across regions of course
you are spanning a very wide area
network in that case so there is a
search charge for that now doing so is
quite simple to do but one of the things
that we have to be mindful of is to give
permissions for the The Source bucket
which has the
originals to allow for this copying of
objects to the destination bucket so if
we're doing this across regions of
course we would have to come up with IM
policies and we would also have to
exchange credentials in terms of uh IM
user credentials in terms of account IDs
and and the such um we're going to be
doing a demonstration in the same
account in the same region but largely
this would be the same steps if we were
going to go cross regions so this is
something you might find yourself doing
if you want to share data with other um
entities in your company maybe you're a
multinational and you want to uh have
all your lock files copied over to
another bucket in another region for
another team to analyze to extract
business insights from or it might just
be that you want to aggregate data in a
separate data Lake uh in an S3 bucket in
another region or in like I said it
could be even in the same region or in
the same account so it's all about
organizing moving data around across
objects across these boundaries and
let's actually go through a
demonstration and see how we can do
crr let's now see how we can perform
cross region replication we're going to
take all the new objects that are going
to be uploaded in the simply learn S3
demo bucket and we're going to replicate
them into a destination bucket so what
we're first going to do is create a new
bucket okay and we'll just tack on the
number two here and this will be our
destination bucket where all those
objects will be replicated too we're
going to demonstrate this within the
same account but it's the exact same
steps when doing this across
regions one of the requirements when
performing cross region replication is
to enable versioning so if you don't do
this you can do it at a later time but
it is NE necessary to enable it at some
point in time before coming up with a
cross region replication rule all right
so let me create that bucket and now
after the bucket is created I want to go
to the source bucket and I want to
configure under the management tab here
a replication rule so I'm going to
create a replication rule call
it simply
learn rep rule
and I'm going to enable this right off
the bat the source bucket of course is
the simply learn S3 demo we could apply
this to all objects in the bucket or
perform a filter once again let's keep
it simple this time and apply to all
objects in the bucket of course caveat
here this will only now apply to any new
objects that are uploaded into this
Source bucket and not the ones that are
already pre existing there okay now in
terms of the a destination bucket we
want to select the one we just created
so we can choose a bucket in this
account or if we really wanted to go
cross region or another account in
another region we could specify this and
put in the account ID and the bucket
name in that other account so we're
going to stay in the same account we're
going to browse and select the newly
created
bucket and we're also going to need
permissions
for the source bucket to dump those
objects into the destination bucket so
we can either create the RO ahead of
time or we can ask this user interface
to create a new role for us so we'll opt
for that and we'll skip these
additional uh features over here that
we're not going to talk about in this
demonstration we're just going to save
this so that will create our replication
rule that is automatically enabled for
for us right
now so let's take a look at the overview
here you can see it's been enabled just
to double check the destination bucket
is the demo 2 we're talking about the
same
region and again here we could opt for
additional um parameters like different
storage classes in the destination
bucket that that object is going to be
deposit in etc etc for now we just
created a simple rule now if we go back
to the original Source bucket which
we're in right now and we upload a new
file which will be transactions file in
a CSV
format once this is
uploaded that cross region replication
rule will kick in and will eventually
right it's not immediate but will
eventually copy the file inside the demo
to bucket now I know it's not there
already so what I'm going to do is pause
the video and come back in 2 minutes and
when I click on this the file should be
in
there okay so let's now double check and
make sure that object has been
replicated and there it is been
replicated as per our rule so
congratulations you just learned how to
perform your first same account S3
bucket region replication
rule
let's now take a look at transfer
acceleration so transfer acceleration is
all about giving your end users the best
possible experience when they're
accessing information in your bucket so
you want to give them the lowest latency
possible you can imagine if you were
serving a
website uh and you wanted people to have
the lowest latency possible of course
that's something that's very desirable
so in terms of traversing long distances
if you have your bucket that is in for
example the US East one region in the
United States in the Virginia region and
you had users let's say in London that
want to access those objects of course
they would have to Traverse a longer
distance than users that were based in
the United States and so if you wanted
to bring those objects closer to them in
terms of latency
then we could take advantage of What's
called the Amazon cloudfront delivery
Network the CDN Network which extends
the AWS backbone by providing what's
called Edge locations so Edge locations
are really data centers that are placed
in major city centers where our end
users mostly are located more densely
populated areas and your objects will be
cached in those locations so if we go
back to the example of your end users
being in London
well they would be accessing a cached
copy of those objects that were stored
in the original bucket in the for
example Us East one region of course you
will get most likely a dramatic
performance increase by enabling
transfer acceleration it's very simple
to uh enable this just bear in mind that
when you do so that you will incur a
charge for using this feature the best
thing to do is to show you how to go
ahead and do this so let's do that right
now let's now take a look at how to
enable transfer acceleration on our
simply learn S3 demo bucket by simply
going to the properties tab we can
scroll down and look for a heading
called transfer acceleration over here
and very simply just enable it
so what does this
do this allows us to take advantage of
What's called the content delivery
Network the CDN which extends the AWS
Network
backbone the CDN network is
strategically placed into more densely
populated areas for example major city
centers and so if your end users are
situated in these more densely populated
areas they will reap the benefits of
having transfer acceleration enabled
because the latency that they will
experience will be severely decreased so
their performance is going to be
enhanced if we take a look at the speed
comparison page for transfer
acceleration we can see that once the
page is finished loading it's going to
do a comparison it's going to perform
first of all what's called a multi-art
upload and it's going to see how
fast that upload was done
with or without transfer acceleration
enabled now this is relative to where I
am running this test so right now I'm
actually running it from Europe so you
can see that I'm getting very very good
results if I would enable transfer
acceleration and my users were based in
Virginia so of course now I have
varying uh differences in percentage as
I go closer or further away from my
region where my bucket or my browser is
being um is being referenced so you can
see here United States I'm getting
pretty good uh percentages as I go
closer to Europe it gets lower of course
but still very very good Frankfurt again
this is about as probably the worst I'm
going to be getting here since I'm
situated in Europe and of course as I go
look more towards you know the Asian
regions you can see once again it kind
of scales up in terms of better
performance
so of course this is an optional feature
once you enable it as I just showed over
here uh this is a feature that you pay
additionally for so bear that in mind
make sure that you take a look at the
pricing page in order to figure out how
much this is going to cost you so that
is it congratulations you just learned
how to Simply enable transfer
acceleration to lower the late and see
from the end users point of
view and with that we have reached the
end of this session and should you need
any assistance PP and other resources
used in this session please let us know
in the comment section below and our
team of experts will be happy to help
you as soon as possible until next time
thank you and keep learning stay tuned
for more from Simply learn staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here